proper transplant with the Obamas you
were at the famous lost kind of white
house party I was there it was scary it
was sad those John I remember I I just
remember like hanging out and like first
of all every black person was there
jay-z Beyonce Oh died it with the black
heavens I remember at one point of the
night I was like with Michelle Obama and
she was like kind of sad and she's like
I don't know what we're gonna do I don't
know what's gonna happen and I was like
[Applause]
we'll be fine and she looks at me and
she goes I was talking about the country
when you go with you all your jokes you
hope that there's obviously there's
different references that they won't get
and some things are very British centric
and I didn't know that if they knew I
have a joke about well it involves the
words hanky-panky
what is it I can't do the whole joke
[Laughter]
Georgia do the Joe it's just a silly
joke it's a joke about words that come
with another word so there's like
chitchat or chap so what's the
difference being chat and chitchat why
these people say John have a chance we
just had a chat we had a bit of chitchat
but it's pretty much the same thing the
difference of course is [ __ ] but people
never have a chip they never go would
you like a chit no I don't have time for
a chat
could we have a little chit but I was
gathered all these words up like like
willy-nilly nitty gritty definite to you
do sometimes get the nitty hurly-burly
dilly-dally wishy-washy ha
and hodgepodge my favorite is
hanky-panky because well everybody hopes
I can only speak as a man but men tend
to hope for hanky-panky on a daily basis
but often we must make do with hanky
[Applause]
sometimes we get to the end of the day
and it looks like pinkies on the cards
what's happening today and we're like
I'm not sure I can do pinkie cuz I went
hanky early daughter but if you can
refrain from hanky there's a good chance
of rampy bumpy I didn't know whether
they had the phrase hanky panky in
Australia tour manager who is the
sweetest smallest Maltese man he's a
tiny sweet malteaser Maltese with the
border so like you've eaten the top and
I said these things great see I said
grats can you go and find out if if they
know the phrase hanky panky because I
don't do this joke and everyone just
stares at me so he went over to the
largest Australian security man I've
ever used beef are you familiar with the
phrase thank you
and it is just like you better get away
from me familiar with it yes it went
very well
okay it's not it's not it's not funny
but it's it I'm interested in what your
opinion is because you can be
underwhelmed you can be overwhelmed
right but you're never just two days ago
well you're right like you could be
distributions with like torrential we'll
always go with rain my favorite is a
Kimbo you can only have links I think
have you seen her dance you'll write the
whelmed this is a good thought if I ever
went solo that would be my name
well no legs a killer
a lovely way of using social media as a
tribute to your partner Jane yeah I just
yeah I like you're in the bar faces that
you do I get the bar faces but then I
also get pictures we if we were out or
something
I sort of like lag behind and get Jane
by herself with no one and I take a
picture of her and I tweet Jane with all
their friends
I don't know how funny Jane finds these
so here's one you choose of Jane Jane
thought you've made a new friend but it
was just a shot Lee what you're
describing Jane
thinking about making new friends no
you're doing it where is he where is it
he sees the tweet this one is Jane is
looking so happy because her new friend
hasn't walked away yet when you're when
she's posing for one of these pictures
does she go is this one of those
pictures where you're gonna make me look
like I have no know there had to be
there hadn't been a few words at home
after you posted this one just found
this photo of Jane when she was little
[Laughter]
well there you go that's it true and
this seems unlikely that you own a
single piece of every bit of memorabilia
that they produced for Lord of the Rings
oh well that's half true so I've got a
few things from the actual film so I
have the ring
I have sting I have a map from Bilbo's
study or the living room in Bag End and
I just recently cuz I went back and did
the final bit on The Hobbit and they
gave me the book that Bilbo writes in he
writes The Hobbit they're in Mac again a
Hobbit's tale and then I finished it as
a lot of the reasons they gave me that
read volume which is oh yeah
whoa and my last day in Hobbiton it was
pretty magical and I was amazing
it's a real place they've actually built
it they built it for Lord of the Rings
we took all of the the facades away and
then it's since been a tourist
attraction and now it's been rebuilt for
The Hobbit but with sustainable
materials with real woods so it'll
always be there so from now on you'll
actually get to see Hobbiton and visit
it as a real place stay there no come
but they are coming the Green Dragon
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes we're going to Hobbiton for
Christmas I turned 19 when we first went
to Hobbiton and all 13 I was talking to
Pete when we were there on my last day I
said you realized that I had my 19th
birthday yeah
[Music]
no one could have known that it was
going to take off and be become a real
place good luck getting into New Zealand
[Applause]
no come on Graham good luck on you he's
a hobbit denier
this is based on your life I mean this
is things yeah loosely crammed things
like isn't the washing machine that
happened to you what the washing you
were very hung over oh yeah
Jodie Foster that story all the stories
are really cool though Graham when I was
teaching this show is based on I I went
home one weekend and I was in my 30s I
was probably 33 years of age I went home
to see my mother and then I went back
and while I was at home my mother did my
washing for me because I was only 33
back on the on the Sunday night I got
really drunk and then I went for a curry
and then the next day I went into school
I'm going to I went into school and it
was a school in Slough and it was quite
a rough school but they had a really
brilliant hearing-impaired Department so
they were hearing impaired kids who you
know struggled they were they were
really looked after in school anyway
I was really hung over I went there and
I bet break time I felt really
uncomfortable I thought something's not
right you know so I went to the toilet
and I pulled my trousers down and some
of my mother's knickers have got I've
got mixed up in the washing and I was
wearing my mother's
oh now I remember you loser this is such
a low point you [ __ ] loser the Korean
food
the Korean the booze kicked in from the
night before I I did like a fecal
Jackson Pollock God not this oh Jesus so
I clean myself up I pulled my mother's
pants back back into the classroom and I
saw one of the hearing impaired kids
like this that's what I remembered my I
had a microphone directly
[Applause]
[Music]
you